Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Le 14 janvier 2022, 7 heures 10 du matin.
Berck sur mer s’éveille dans le froid
de ce matin de janvier.
Un regard, un visage, une rencontre.
Une rencontre unilatérale, courte.
Tellement courte qu’il n’aura ni le temps
de me dire son nom,
ni même un mot, ni même un regard.
Pourtant, ce regard,
je ne l’oublierai plus.
Ce même regard, je le recroiserai
quelques minutes plus tard
au travers du visage d’un grand frère,
à peine plus âgé que lui.
Ce visage que je n’oublie pas,
je mettrai plusieurs semaines
à découvrir son prénom, Azzedine.
Azzedine, c’est l’histoire d’un gamin
né du mauvais côté d’une frontière
et qui, avec son frère,
a décidé de fuir la guerre,
l’horreur, la violence.
Cette quête d’une vie meilleure va
s’arrêter en ce matin de janvier 2022,
à quelques dizaines de kilomètres
de son rêve de liberté.
Nous récupérerons Azzedine à quelques
centaines de mètres du rivage, en mer.
Mort noyé, mort gelé,
tombé d’une embarcation qui tentait
de rejoindre illégalement le Royaume-Uni.
Azzedine,
c’est l’histoire d’un grand frère aussi
que nous allons secourir quelques minutes
plus tard avec 25 autres personnes.
Azzedine, c’est aussi un drame,
celui de son grand frère
qui ne pourra pas tenir sa promesse
d’emmener son petit frère
dans un lieu sécurisé et en sérénité.
Mai 2022, c’est la nuit noire.
Des cris, Des hurlements.
C'est la panique.
Une soixantaine de personnes à l’eau.
Eux aussi se retrouvent à l’eau
suite à l’échec du départ
de leur embarcation
vers leur eldorado britannique.
C’est la panique, ai-je dit.
Personne ne sait nager.
Des hommes, des femmes,
des enfants et même des bébés.
Ils sont tous apeurés.
Et pourtant, nous allons réussir
avec mon équipage
à faire ce que nous pensions impossible :
les ramener en sécurité sur le sable
malgré les courants de marées
et les enrochements.
Au-dessus de nos têtes, un bruit sourd.
C’est l’hélicoptère, celui de la Marine
nationale, notre soutien,
notre ange-gardien,
mais aussi présent
pour une évacuation médicale.
Ils sont tous choqués, résignés,
résignés d’avoir échoué
dans leur tentative d’aller en Angleterre.
Mais personne ne veut être séparé,
même pour une urgence cardiaque.
J’ai beau négocier, parlementer,
promettre à un papa qui me parle en arabe
et son fils qui me répond en anglais
et qui retraduit derrière,
mais rien n’y fait,
l’union est plus forte que la raison.
Ils sont aussi
effondrés,
résignés d’avoir échoué
et d’avoir perdu plus de 3 500€.
3 500€, c’est le prix d’une place
qu’ils doivent payer
dans ces embarcations de fortune
pour tenter de rejoindre le Royaume-Uni.
L'intervention est terminée.
3 heures 30 du matin,
je rentre chez moi,
non pas avec un sentiment de fierté,
mais avec la sérénité qu’avec mon équipage
nous avons accompli un petit miracle :
ramener ces gens sains et saufs à terre.
À terre, plutôt par terre,
car sur le chemin du retour,
je retrouve une douzaine de personnes,
deux familles, dont deux mamans
avec leur bébé dans les bras,
allongées par terre au bord de la route,
tentant d’arracher quelques minutes,
quelque répit, un peu de sommeil
à cette nuit si hostile.
À terre, qui pour les aider ?
Personne.
Ce seraient des chiens,
on appellerait la SPA.
Mais là, que faire ?
Un coup de téléphone, demi-tour.
Je récupère un peu d’habits,
de la boisson, des biscuits.
Pas grand-chose en fait.
Mais je vais passer avec ces gens
plus de deux heures d’une grande humanité.
Il y aura des regards,
des accolades, des mains serrées,
quelques mercis,
des mots malencontreusement traduits
sur un téléphone
et enfin quelques sourires.
Quelques doudous aussi pour les enfants,
que j’ai toujours
dans mon sac d’intervention.
Ça permet d’endormir les enfants
et surtout d’apaiser les parents.
Les gendarmes passeront, s’arrêteront
et comme moi auront le même sentiment,
le même sentiment d’impuissance.
Ils ne peuvent rien faire et comme moi,
ils offriront un peu d’humanité.
Une situation irréelle mais bien réelle.
Je suis quelqu'un comme vous.
Rien d'exceptionnel.
Je suis un papa, je suis un mari.
J'ai beaucoup de défauts,
quelques qualités.
Mais j’ai surtout la grande chance,
l’honneur et la fierté
de diriger une équipe de bénévoles
aux valeurs et aux sentiments d’humanité
qui nous permettent de réaliser
de belles choses.
Tout ceci réuni sous la bannière
des Sauveteurs en mer.
Nous sommes tous bénévoles.
Des pères, des mères, des enfants,
des retraités, des actifs.
Nous intervenons 365 jours par an H24
pour sauver toutes les personnes
en difficulté en mer,
et ce, quelle que soit leur origine.
Nous ne faisons aucune politique.
Toute cette magnifique équipe
nous permet de réaliser des miracles.
Et parfois nous avons quelques échecs
et nous devons apprendre à vivre avec ça.
Depuis janvier 2020,
la crise migratoire
est arrivée sur nos côtes.
Elle n’est plus désormais réservée
à la Méditerranée.
Avec nos collègues des quatre autres
stations des Hauts-de-France,
nous devons faire face
à ces tentatives nombreuses
de traversées vers le Royaume-Uni.
Ces traversées vendues à prix d’or
par des réseaux mafieux, par des passeurs,
par des chiens sans aucun respect
pour la vie humaine,
qui désormais entassent
plus de 80 personnes
dans des bateaux de piètre qualité,
sans aucun moyen de sécurité,
ni même de communication.
Ces passeurs,
ces chiens, vont jusqu’à leur vendre
des gilets de sauvetage contrefaits.
Novembre 2021.
Triste record.
Il est 1 h du matin, nos téléphones
sonnent : une nouvelle alerte.
Nous faisons route au sud, ici, à quelques
dizaines de kilomètres en baie de Somme,
devant les lieux de villégiature picarde.
À la radio, des cris, des hurlements,
des pêcheurs qui demandent de l’aide
parce qu’ils entendent autour d’eux,
dans la nuit noire, des appels au secours.
Nous arrivons très rapidement
et nous constatons avec effroi
une nouvelle scène.
Un bateau rempli de 40 personnes,
le flanc bâbord complètement crevé
qui commence à se remplir d’eau.
C'est la panique.
Mais nous savons faire,
nous stabilisons la situation.
Nous prenons dans notre radeau de survie
les femmes, les enfants
et les plus vulnérables.
Nous embarquons avec nous les blessés
et réussissons à figer cette situation.
Nous attendons l’arrivée
d’un plus gros bateau
pour pouvoir transférer
les personnes sur ce bateau.
Durant ce moment d'attente,
je vais faire un constat.
Le constat que leur plus grande peur
est que nous les abandonnions
à leur propre sort,
comme ce qui est fait en Méditerranée.
Le bateau les embarque
et nous refaisons route,
vers chez nous avec nos blessés.
Le soleil commence à se lever.
C'est le petit matin.
A quelques kilomètres de notre arrivée,
nous tombons sur une nouvelle embarcation,
une vingtaine de personnes,
elles aussi en difficulté.
Nous arriverons à les ramener
sains et saufs à terre.
Et quelques minutes avant d’arriver, nous
recroiserons une nouvelle embarcation.
50 personnes qui prennent la mer, tentant
elles aussi de rejoindre le Royaume-Uni.
Ces mêmes personnes seront secourues
quelques heures plus tard.
Quelques jours plus tard, nos collègues
de Calais auront à affronter
un naufrage qui fera 27 victimes.
Il y a sept ans, quand j’ai intégré
les Sauveteurs en mer,
j’ai voulu apporter mes compétences
aquatiques de nageur d’eau libre.
Au fil des ans, des sauvetages,
des formations, des diplômes,
j’ai endossé le rôle de patron.
Le patron sauveteur en mer, c’est
le capitaine, le chef opérationnel.
C'est celui qui doit toujours prendre
les bonnes décisions.
C'est celui qui doit aussi se justifier
auprès des officiels.
Le patron, dans mon cas, c’est aussi
celui qu’on traite d’inconscient
parce qu’il va ramener
plus de 30 personnes dans un bateau
qui ne peut en contenir que douze.
Le patron, toujours dans mon cas,
c’est celui qu’on va dire irresponsable
parce qu’un petit matin d’un mois
de février dans une eau à cinq degrés,
nous allons récupérer avec trois autres
membres de mon équipage -
parce que notre bateau n’embarque
que quatre personnes -
une trentaine de personnes,
dont trois enfants.
On me reprochera d’embarquer des enfants
dans un bateau sans cabine
et sans chauffage, en train de couler.
Par contre, le patron,
c’est celui qu’on va féliciter
le jour où il ira chercher un plaisancier
sans aucune expérience de la mer, qui va
se croire plus fort que les éléments
et qui aura la bonne idée
d’aller affronter la tempête.
Ces migrants, comme on les appelle,
c’est avant tout des gens
comme vous, comme moi,
qui ont le droit à une vie en sécurité.
Ces gens prennent la mer
non pas par plaisir,
mais par nécessité de vivre,
de survivre et de revivre.
Ils sont bien plus souvent reconnaissants
que bon nombre de vacanciers,
de plaisanciers
que nous allons secourir aussi.
Comment ne pas penser
à cette famille d’Albanais ?
Un petit matin de juillet que
nous extirpons de la mer
et que nous ramenons trempés sur la plage.
Ces gens, un papa, une maman
et deux petits enfants,
dans les heures qui vont suivre
ce naufrage n’auront qu’une idée en tête :
nous retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux pour nous remercier.
Nous sommes sauveteurs en mer,
nous sommes bénévoles,
nous finançons l’achat, l’entretien
de nos propres moyens de sauvetage.
Nous nous formons pour constamment
développer nos techniques de sauvetage
et être plus réactifs.
Nous sommes fiers de faire perdurer
l'entraide entre marins.
Le sauvetage de la vie humaine
en mer est totalement gratuit.
Nous faisons tout ça par engagement.
Nous allons secourir les gens.
Quel que soit le pavillon du bateau,
quelle que soit la nationalité,
leur origine, leur langue, leur religion
et leur couleur de peau,
nous ne faisons aucune distinction.
Nous ne faisons aucune politique.
J’ai bien conscience que tout le monde
ne peut pas embarquer avec nous.
Mais tout le monde peut nous soutenir pour
que nous puissions continuer d’embarquer.
Et croyez-moi, nous ferons tous ensemble
le maximum de choses
pour éviter le maximum de drames
sur notre côte.
Je ne suis pas là ce soir
pour ouvrir un débat.
Je veux juste vous ouvrir les yeux -
je veux juste vous ouvrir les yeux
sur ce qui se passe désormais
quasiment chaque nuit de beau temps
sur nos côtes,
et ce tout au long de l’année.
Ces rencontres, ces sauvetages,
ces échanges,
m’ont ouvert les yeux sur la grande
détresse, sur la grande misère
de notre monde,
mais aussi m’ont rassuré, conforté
sur le fait qu’il y a encore des personnes
avec des vraies valeurs humaines.
Ce soir, je suis là aussi
pour rendre hommage
à tous les autres acteurs
du sauvetage en mer en Manche.
Nous ne sommes pas les seuls.
Et également à tous les autres acteurs
qui interviennent dans ces drames humains.
J’ai conscience que
nous ne sauverons pas le monde.
Par contre, j’ai la certitude
que chacun d’entre nous
peut améliorer, peut sauver
le monde qui l’entoure.
Et je terminerai juste en répondant
à ces bien-penseurs qui nous disent
que d’aller sauver ces gens,
c’est un problème.
Je leur répondrai juste que ce problème,
c’est le leur et pas le mien.
(Applaudissements)